Just another way of looking at the same concept.
Here this is the film thing.
Light comes in from down here.
There is protective coating.
The emulsion is where most of the details of the the light silver halides and
everything else is.
The adhesive, and there's the base, and
of course that's covered up to prevent it from getting damaged across the board.
Sounds simple, and basically, it's a very interesting process.
You know, full credit to the people who innovated this whole idea ways
back when.
And some of the earliest cameras, as we talked about before,
were developed in the mid 1800's.
Purely a chemical process, and
of course, it took them a while to even figure out how to preserve and save and
then print out, develop and print out, from these chemical processes.